this morning we're going to continue our
series we call it never too late where
you find out how it really is never too
late for a new chapter that's good news
a movie World Legend who's always worked
behind the scenes is having a surprising
Revival you could say Renato casaro's
his name his iconic movie posters
promoted new releases for decades but
his beautiful hand-drawn work fell out
of favor and fashion when Studios turned
to digital Graphics now as Chris livesay
reports the 86 year old artist is back
thanks to one commission that changed
everything
he's the Michelangelo of movie posters
but chances are you don't know his name
over the course of 50 years Renato
cazaro has drawn the first impressions
of some of our favorite films it's like
a sculpture posters he Likens to bait on
a hook it's up the crystal sensory
unless you give away the better like in
dances with walls this Mark says it all
helping turn movies into milestones and
mere mortals into
starsimo oh you can't do this
born 86 years ago here in Treviso Italy
kazaro got his start as a teenager
drawing posters for local theaters in
exchange for tickets
[Music]
his big break came when iconic Italian
filmmaker Dino De Laurentiis was making
his epic Blockbuster the Bible
it was a colossal film my posters were
put on billboards on Sunset Boulevard
after that my phone never stopped
ringing
James Bond The Last Emperor the
never-ending story a never-ending list
of commissions thanks to an uncanny gift
for building a film up by stripping it
down the movie has you know 100 minutes
where it can tell this story all you
have is one frame how do you choose that
one scene that how do you choose that
one picture that's going to become the
poster
it takes a lot of Scribbles the table
gets covered in them and then you throw
them away slowly you narrow it down you
subtract you don't add the poster of
Nikita shows a woman with a back turned
beyond the bathroom door it makes you
wonder what just happened the viewer
says I have to go and see what this film
is all about
and see them they did more than 2 000
posters bear his signature until one day
the phone stopped ringing software like
Photoshop he says had put him out of a
job
with all the action films of today it's
very easy to generate a spectacular
image
then after 17 years his phone finally
rang again it was none other than
Quentin Tarantino he was shooting Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood Leonardo
DiCaprio plays a fading movie star in
1969. Brad Pitt plays his stunt double
kill me quick Ringo said the Gringo
Tarantino needed a vintage poster so he
turned to a vintage artist this is the
poster you designed yes for the film
inside the film I get it okay Tarantino
sent him this thank you okay so it says
to Renato Casado thanks so much for your
art gracing my picture you've always
been my favorite so this is Tarantino's
the spotlight long overdue was finally
cast on Cesaro
a kazaro retrospective is now touring
Italy and even streaming services are
buying new works oh this is for Netflix
oh wow new technology offering a job
instead of putting him out of it you
have all of Hollywood here yes Hollywood
giveth and Hollywood taketh away he says
as a poster artist we weren't considered
part of the production our names were
never in the credits because I see your
work and I realize I've been a fan my
whole life without even realizing it
everyone tells me that he says but now
thanks to an unlikely third act his
countless fans can finally know his name
for CBS mornings Chris livesay and
Treviso Italy
yeah I bet you looked at those posters
and go I know that one I know for sure
nicely done he's the man who beckoned
you into the theater yeah one of my
favorite Parts about going to a movie is
walking to the theater and seeing the
posters and saying oh that's coming out
I got to check that out we've probably
seen his over and over again yeah Rambo
now we know the classic
gun it's amazing how that worked all
right coming up